[Musique]
le gouvernement n'a pas apporté de
mesures ambitieuses et en particulier au
soutien aux familles on a un problème en
france qui est le problème du
renouvellement des générations
le problème de la natalité on sent qu'il
ya une certaine inquiétude chez les
jeunes dans les familles il n'y a plus
d'espoir ou d'espérance c'est comme on
veut les mesures d'accompagnement
famille ont été rognés au fur et à
mesure des différents belle fss le
gouvernement n'est pas revenu sur ses
dispositions bien au contraire pêcheries
la sous- revaloriser l'allocation
familiale dont toutes ces mesures en
fait ne sont pas incitative pour
redonner confiance aux français dans la
famille pour renouveler les générations
mais aussi pour assurer les retraites à
l'avenir
[Musique]
dans
les faits c'est c'est des dispositifs en
faveur des familles le sénat et sa
majorité pourrait proposer de nouvelles
dispositions mais ces dispositions en
fait ne font qu'ouvrir le départ puisque
pour que ces mesures soient retenues que
ces propositions soient retenues il faut
qu'elle soit financée et à ce niveau là
c'est pas nous qui avons la main mais
c'est le gouvernement qui va accepter ou
non ces propositions de financement
[Musique]